regardez une innovation française qui
vient rapprocher les gens ça s'appelle
la vitre c'est des Nantais et alors
derrière vous avez une équipe qui est à
Nantes et qui vous fait coucou et alors
en fait ce qui est génial c'est que vous
voyez c'est un énorme écran alors que on
est dans un moment où on vous vante le
métamère son sens enferme avec des
casques et bien eux ils ont fait tout le
chemin inverse ils prennent des très
grands écrans pour venir communiquer
directement avec des équipes à l'autre
bout du monde ou même dans un bureau à
côté pourquoi pas la solution est
marrant parce qu'en plus vous pouvez
venir totalement interagir par exemple
ici avec des petits panneaux nanoleaf
regardez à Nantes ils ont de l'anneau
lisse derrière et bien moi je peux venir
modifier la couleur derrière en temps
réel et il y a plein d'usage qui peuvent
venir partager l'écran de leur
smartphone ici pour du travail
collaboratif bref c'est une solution
française et l'innovation qui va
totalement à contre-courant et qui est
beaucoup plus humanisante et qui permet
de rapprocher les gens au lieu de créer
des distances et de créer des variables
je trouve ça marrant boîte nantaise la
vitre dites-moi ce que vous en pensez
est-ce que vous dans votre milieu
professionnel c'est quelque chose qui
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que vous
êtes sensible si oui d'ailleurs ben vous
pouvez marquer dans les commentaires
allez-y